[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit
kaiselberichter und dunia
Hayali schönen guten Abend in der EU
sind sich alle Mitgliedstaaten einig die
Asylpolitik muss reformiert worden
werden in uneinig war man sich aber über
das Wie jahrelang gab es darüber
Diskussionen und heute man höre und
staune tatsächlich eine Einigung diese
soll nun die illegale Migration stoppen
das Sterben auf dem Mittelmeer beenden
und zu einer gerechten Verteilung
innerhalb der EU führen kritiker sagen
alles Quatsch nichts davon wird
eintreten geht es also bei der Reform
weniger um inhaltlich sinnvolle wie
umsetzbare Lösungen sondern viel mehr
darum Handlungsfähigkeit zu beweisen ein
Schelm der dabei an die europaahlen im
Juni denkt Julia rech und Ulf
röer die Kulisse passt so gar nicht zur
selbstbeweihäucherung durch einen leeren
pressesal halt das Lob der eupitzen zur
Einigung das ist eine historischer
Tag bis zum Morgen dauerte es bis die EU
Geschichte
machteen Bits eine gemeinsame
Migrationspolitik verabschiedete das
Versprechen an die Bürger ist
groß wir brauchten einen Kompromiss der
human und fair für die ist die
schutzuchen der die ablehnt die keinen
asylanspruch haben und der die bekämpft
die das Leid der Migranten ausnutzen das
haben wir
hinbekommen die Reform des gemeinsamen
europäischen Asylsystems sieht unter
anderem beschleunigte Asylverfahren an
den EU Außengrenzen vor für diejenigen
die sowieso nur geringe Chancen auf Asyl
haben zudem soll das Konzept des
sicheren Drittstaats ausgeweitet werden
Asylbewerber können ohne asylprüfung in
diese Drittstaaten zurückgewiesen werden
und außerdem sollen Flüchtlinge
innerhalb der EU solidarisch verteilt
werden um Kommunen dauerhaft zu
entlasten brauchen sie europäische
Regelungen die zu einer besseren
Verteilung innerhal
beitragen die Verteilung der Flüchtlinge
funktioniert nur wenn alle solidarisch
sind Ungarn stellt nach wenigen Stunden
den Kompromiss gleich in Frage will
nicht mitmachen die EUKommission
warnt die Kommission ist dafür
verantwortlich dass sich jedes
Mitgliedsland an die Gesetze hält wer
das nicht tut muss mit Konsequenzen
rechnen kein Thema hat Europa so
aufgewühlt wie die Migration und kein
Thema steht so für den Aufstieg der
Rechtspopulisten die Angst dass diese
Parteien bei der Europawahl triumphieren
träte zum
Kompromiss wir haben eine europäische
verantwortungsvolle Lösung gefunden die
rechtsextrem propagieren genau das
Gegenteil nämlich nationale Lösungen sie
verbreiten Illusionen sie ignorieren
Europas
Rechtsstaat ja der Rechtsstaat die EU
hofft dass der Kompromiss Migranten von
der Flucht nach Europa abhält sie will
damit tragische Momente wie den Brand im
Moria oder die vielen Ertrunkenen
verhindern kritiker bezweifeln dass das
gelingt wir fürchten dass wir die
schlechtesten Aspekte der letzten Jahre
halt weitersehen werden das heißt auch
Tote im Mittelmeer das heißt brutale
pushbacks an den Außengrenzen das heißt
eben gerade auch Haftzentren an den
Außengrenzen wo keine fernasyverfahren
möglich sind die EU hat sich geeinigt
historisch so richtig sprang der Funke
im Saal nicht
über vielleicht springt er ja über auf
Gerald Knaus er ist der Ideengeber für
den EU Türkei Deal und
migrationsforschern damit einen schönen
guten Abend nach bolologonna schönen
guten Abend hat diese Reform denn jetzt
wirklich mal Hand und Fuß also wird sie
eine Verbesserung
bringen also um es ganz kurz zu sagen
ich fürchte weder die irreguläre
Migration noch die sekundär Migration in
der EU noch die Zahl der Abschiebungen
ausreisepflichtiger noch die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen an den
Außengrenzen werden dadurch gestoppt
diese verpflichteten grenzverfahren
können das nicht erreichen das klingt
ziemlich desaströs also ihr Urteil also
wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden
habe es wird im Großen und Ganzen gar
nichts verändern wird es denn was für
die anreinerländern wie z.B Italien
verbessern also ich fürchte dass es
gerade für ein Land wie Italien
praktisch unmöglich ist das durchzu zu
also umzusetzen allerdings sind auch
einige Lücken in dem Gesetzestext z.B
muss man diese grenzverfahren gar nicht
an den Grenzen machen wenn wir im
letzten Jahr jede Woche im Durchschnitt
3000 Menschen kommen dann ist es
eigentlich unvorstellbar diese Verfahren
oder diese Aufnahmezentren in Lampedusa
oder Sizilien zu machen man wird sie in
Italien verteilen müssen und dann wird
so sein wie heute und das heißt dass
Italien möglicherweise die geflüchteten
gar nicht aufhalten kann oder aber auch
gar nicht will damit ist ja dann auch
Deutschland überhaupt nicht geholfen
dabei hat der Bundeskanzler heute gesagt
es sei alles ein wichtiger Beschluss
damit wir Deutschland entlastet ja das
Grundproblem ist sehr sehr einfach wenn
Spanien Italien Griechenland aber auch
Frankreich und Deutschland nicht in der
Lage sind die die Europa reichen
zurückzubringen auch die die
ausreisepflichtig sind oder andere um
sie zu entmutigen in sichere
Drittstaaten wenn das gar nicht klappt
und es klappt derzeit gar nicht und es
steht nichts in diesem Kompromiss dass
es möglich macht macht dann werden die
Leute die ankommen bleiben und dann gibt
es auch keinen Grund für sie nicht mehr
in die Bote zu steigen und das heißt vor
allen Dingen auch für Deutschland dass
die Länder und Kommunen nicht entlastet
werden wenn sie mit all dem was sie
gerade sagen Recht haben dann scheint ja
wirklich niemandem geholfen zu sein was
heißt das denn eigentlich dass die EU
sich selbst veräppelt und gleich die
Bürger alle
mit nein ich glaube die die da
verhandelt haben wollten das richtige
erreichen im Einklang mit den
Menschenrecht irreguläre Migration
reduzieren der einzige der das gar nicht
will ist Viktor Orban aber wir erkennen
hier dass die EU an ihre Grenzen stößt
das was man Staaten anbieten muss damit
es klappt das können nur Nationalstaaten
die Staaten haben unterschiedliche
Interessen wichtig ist dass jetzt
niemand darauf wartet dass sich das
Problem durch diese Gesetze löst sondern
deutschland und andere vorangehen in den
nächsten Monaten vor den
europaparlamentswahlen und beweisen dass
humane Kontrolle durch strategische
migrationsabkommen immer noch möglich ja
und auch umgesetzt werden kann aber
dafür sollte doch jetzt genau diese
Reform da sein also dass das was in den
letzten Jahren versucht wurde nicht
funktioniert hat sehen wir ja denn immer
wieder setzen sich Menschen in die Boote
die Schlepper machen immer weiter ihre
Geschäfte also deswegen ist es doch
jetzt mehr als verwirrend dass das was
jetzt beschlossen wurde nach all den
Verhandlungen im Grunde gar nichts
bringt ja das ist enttäuschend aber ich
sage Ihnen ehrlich wenn ich mit
Innenministerien in ganz Europa spreche
und sie of ört also inoffiziell sprechen
dann erwarten auch die Innenminister in
oder die Innenministerien in Ländern die
sie als harliner gelten von dieser
Reformen keine wirkliche Veränderung
also ja vor der Reform also nach der
Reform ist leider vor der Reform man
muss jetzt das machen was man immer
schon machen musste diese Reform wird
uns nicht helfen es ist ja auch so dass
Familien mit Kindern egal wie alt die
müssen zur Prüfung jetzt auch in die
Auffanglager manche sprechen da auch von
Internierungslagern die in Ministerin
die deutsche war eigentlich dagegen dann
hat sie gesagt sollte es doch so kommen
dann wird Deutschland doch
mitstimmen verstehen Sie diese
Entscheidung also verstehen Sie diesen
politischen
Druck ich glaube hier wurde viel
vermischt wir haben natürlich weiterhin
die Menschenrechtskonvention und auch
schon bisher war es so dass die
dublinreeln natürlich ausgesetzt wurden
wenn sie gegen die
Menschenrechtskonvention verstoßen drum
gibt's ja keine überrückführungen nach
Griechenland auch die Haft von egal wem
oder das festhalten muss den Standards
der Menschenrechtskonvention entsprechen
die Krise die wir derzeit haben ist eine
andere das auch Politiker in Europa
beginnen darüber nachzudenken um
irreguläre Migration zu reduzieren die
Menschenrechtskonvention und den
Menschenrechtsgerichtshof außen
vorzulassen wie Viktor Orban oder die
englische Regierung und das ist eine
wahre Gefahr denn dann gibt es keinen
Schutz mehr der Menschenwürde und der
Grundrechte sagt der Migrationsforscher
Gerald Knaus vielen Dank für ihre
Einschätzung ich danke ihnen Grüße aus
bologia und das Gespräch haben wir
aufgezeichnet und damit direkt zur
nächsten Reform die heute in Brüssel auf
den Weg gebracht wurde da geht es um die
EU Schuldenregeln die gelten seit gut 25
Jahren und fast seit genauso vielen
Jahren gibt es Kritik daran denn sie
haben verschuldete Länder eher noch mehr
in die Krise gestürzt was zur Folge
hatte dass die Länder immer mal wieder
gegen sie verstoßen haben übrigens auch
Deutschland und das ohne nennenswerte
Konsequenzen also was soll eine Regel
die nichts bringt und an die sich keiner
hält hat man sich dann wohl auch in
Brüssel gefragt und so wurde monatelang
verhandelt und heute nun gehandelt die
EU Finanzminister haben sich auf eine
neue Reform geeinigt Gunner Krüger für
uns in Brüssel hat das ganze beobachtet
Gunner der Vorschlag kam ja von
Deutschland und Frankreich die anderen
Länder gehen dann jetzt wohl mit was
konkret ändert sich denn
da ändern sich einfach die Regeln wie EU
wie in den EU-Staaten die Haushalte
aufgestellt werden müssen die letzte
Staatsschuldenkrise die hatte ja zwei
Lehren parat zum einen wurde klar die
Schulden sind zu hoch die Defizite sind
zu hoch dadurch steigen die Zinsen die
müssen also runter zugleich wurde aber
auch klar dass diese starrenreeln also
z.B 60% beim Schuldenstand oder 3% beim
Defizit dass die eben manche Staaten
noch weiter in die Schuldenfalle
reintreiben und so gibt es jetzt zwei
Änderung die eine betrifft die
EU-Kommission die bekommt ein bisschen
mehr macht die schaut sich über mehrere
Jahre jetzt an wie sind die Länder bei
ihren Schulden aufgestellt sind die
tragfähig wie entwickeln sich die Zinsen
das Wirtschaftswachstum und dann kann
die EU-Kommission eben auch Ausnahmen
zulassen und weil manche Mitgliedstaaten
da ein bisschen misstrausch sind
gegenüber der EU-Kommission auch
Deutschland gibt es eine zweite
Neuregelung das sind Haltelinien die
sagen besonders hochverschuldete Staaten
die müssen ein besonders das geringes
Defizit anstreben also unterm Strich es
gibt ein bisschen Lockerung ein bisschen
flexiblere Regeln die sollen jetzt aber
auch eingehalten werden und wenn das
wirklich passiert dann wäre dieser Pakt
was sein Name verspricht eben einer für
Wachstum aber eben auch für Stabilität
also Brüssel zeigt sich heute
handlungsaktiv zwei Einigungen an einem
Tag Asyl und EU Schuldenregeln wer oder
was sitzt denn der EU im Nacken also
ganz klar rechtspopulistische Parteien
in vielen eu-mgliedstaaten wir haben das
zuletzt in Italien in den Niederlanden
gesehen diese EU-Kommission stützt sich
ja auf eine relativ knappe Mehrheit wenn
es also mehr Stimmen gäbe für
rechtspopulistische Parteien dann wäre
eben Gesetzesarbeit hier in Brüssel noch
schwieriger und tatsächlich könnte dann
eben auch eine Mehrheit für eine
Kommission schwer zu bilden sein diese
beiden Themen die sind ja äh miteinander
nicht verknüpft aber die haben doch eben
eins gemeinsam und das haben wir hier in
mehreren Jahren waren am Jahresende
gesehen so eine Art Jahresendrally da
wird durchgepalscht was man über Monate
verschleppt hat aber das ganze findet
jetzt unter verschärften Bedingungen
statt weil eben im nächsten Jahr gewählt
wird was jetzt nicht in den Gremien in
den Institutionen beschlossen wird das
kommt nicht mehr durchs Parlament und
das verfällt dann also der
Handlungsdruck ist da vor allen Dingen
der Druck Handlungsfähigkeit zu zeigen
auch wenn die Konsequenzen oder die die
Folgen von diesen Reformen vielleicht
gar nicht so signifikant sind aber das
Wichtige ist dass die EU zeigt sie kann
Handeln gerade beim Thema Asyl anes
andere wäre in den Mitgliedstaaten
verheerend beschließen ist das eine
umsetzen das andere Gunner Krüger vielen
Dank und wir machen jetzt hier weiter
mit dem Thema Zuwanderung kaisölve und
blicken dafür aber nach Frankreich genau
denn auch dort wurden die
einwanderungsregeln massiv verschärft
was für erhebliche Spannungen sorgt im
Parlament brauchte Präsident macron die
Stimmen der Rechtspopulisten rund ein
Viertel des Regierungslagers stimmte
dagegen aus protestrat
Gesundheitsminister so zurück das Gesetz
sieht unter anderem vor dass nicht
EU-Ausländer künftig erst nach 5 Jahren
Sozialleistungen beziehen können da es
rechtliche Zweifel an den neuen Regeln
gibt soll der Verfassungsrat das Gesetz
überprüfen in Deutschland hat sich die
Ampelkoalition auf einen Kompromiss
geeinigt der schärfere Regeln bei der
Abschiebung vorsieht so könnten Menschen
ohne bleibeerecht künftig bis zu 28 Tage
in Ausreise Gewahrsam genommen werden
bisher sind es zehn außerdem bekommt die
Bundespolizei mehr die Polizei überhaupt
mehr Befugnisse z.B bei Durchsuchungen
von Unterkünften das Gesetz soll im
Januar vom Bundestag beschlossen werden
bereits auf den Weg gebracht hat die
Bundesregierung das neue Polizeigesetz
es soll die Befugnisse der Bundespolizei
erweitern z.B bei der Telefonüberwachung
und beim Einsatz von Drohnen ein
weiteres Ziel ist mehr Transparenz so
soll jede von Bundespolizisten befragte
Person eine Kontrol volquittung
verlangen können außerdem gilt für
Bundespolizisten künftig eine
Kennzeichnungspflicht 11 Wochen nach der
vermeintlichen Attacke auf AFD Chef
krupalla hat die ingolstäter
Staatsanwaltschaft ihre Ermittlungen
eingestellt man habe weder Hinweise auf
eine Straftat noch auf eine injizierte
Substanz finden können Kaller hatte bei
einer wlkampfveranstaltung im Oktober
über Beschwerden geklagt daraufhin wurde
er ins Krankenhaus gebracht am Arm hatte
er einen sch die AFD spricht von einem
Anschlag und prüft nun eine Beschwerde
gegen die
Entscheidung es ist ein Paukenschlag für
die polnische Medienlandschaft die neue
Regierung hat die komplette
Führungsriege des öffentlichrechtlichen
Rundfunks entlassen die Anstalten waren
zum Sprachrohr der Nationalkonservativen
Vorgängerregierung geworden gegen die
Entscheidung demonstrieren Anhänger der
bisher Regierenden peacepartei sie haben
sich vor dem Fernsehsender TVP
versammelt der heute keine
Hauptnachrichten sendete morgen soll das
Programm unter einer neuen Führung
wieder aufgenommen
werden es ist ein historisches Urteil
möglicherweise mit weitreichenden Folgen
für die Präsidentenwahl im
US-Bundesstaat Colorado hat das Oberste
Gericht Donald Trump von den dortigen
Vorwahlen ausgeschlossen der 77-Jährige
sei für das Präsidentenamt nicht
geeignet hintergrund ist die Erstürmung
des Kapitols im Januar
2021 der abgewählte Trump hatte seine
Anhänger damals angestachelt es gilt als
wahrscheinlich dass er Berufung beim
obersten US-Gericht
einliegt er hätte damals nach seiner
Vergiftung mit dem nervenkampfstoff
novitchock einfach in Deutschland
bleiben können ist er aber nicht nach 32
Tagen Behandlung hat navalni die
Berliner charit verlassen und gegen
eigene Gefängniszelle in Russland
eingetauscht denn nach seiner Rückkehr
am 17 Januar 2021 wurde er dort umgehend
festgenommen inhaftiert und kurz darauf
verurteilt soweit so schlecht aber nun
ist er auch noch verschwunden seit
Anfang Dezember fehlt von dem schärfsten
Gegner des russischen Präsidenten jede
Spur angeblich wurde er in eine andere
Haftanstalt verlegt wieso weshalb wohin
alles unklar Nina
Niebergall wo ist Alexi navalni das will
auch jeevgen stup wissen er hat eine
Anfrage an das Moskauer Stadtparlament
gestellt als Oppositionspolitiker und
Anwalt als einziger aus dem Exil seit er
sich offen gegen Putins Krieg
ausgesprochen hat lebt er gefährlich wir
treffen ihn deshalb in
Armenien wenn navalni im Gefängnis nicht
über den Krieg gesprochen hätte wenn er
nicht gesagt hätte wie zerstörerisch
Putins Herrschaft für die Russen ist
hätten sie ihn in Ruhe gelassen vor
allem mit Blick auf die anstehende
Präsidentschaftswahl sehen die Behörden
Putins Macht
bedroht weltweit Fragen seine
Unterstützer auf Social Media Putin wo
ist navalni seit 15 Tagen fehlt von
Russlands bekanntestem kremmelkritiker
jede Spur kann es sein dass er tot
ist in russischen Gefängnissen sterben
Menschen nicht weil sie jemand gezielt
töten will sondern weil es niemanden
interessiert
deshalb habe ich natürlich bedenken was
das Leben und das Schicksal von navalni
angeht gesundheitlich geht es navalni
schon länger schlecht wegen der
novichchock Vergiftung
2020 dazu die katastrophalen
Haftbedingungen im Straflager wo er
immer wieder in Isolationshaft muss seit
di Jahren sitzt navalni im Gefängnis und
ist trotzdem Russlands wichtigste
oppositionsstimme das weiß auch Putin
weggesperrt aber nicht mundtot über
seine Anwälte schafft navalni es immer
wieder politische Statements wie diese
zu
veröffentlichen um seine eigene Macht zu
verlängern zerfleischt Putin das
Nachbarland tötet dort Menschen und dazu
wirft er noch eine riesige Zahl
russischer Menschen in den
Fleischwolf fast zeitgleich mit navalnis
verschwinden ging diese Kampagne online
darin ruft sein Team die Russen auf im
März für andere Kandidaten zu stimmen
nur nicht für
Putin ist das dem Kremmel kurz vor der
Präsidentschaftswahl zu heikel geworden
Beweise gibt es nicht angeblich sei
navalni in ein anderes Straflager
verlegt
worden sie haben es sich zur Aufgabe
gemacht navalni zu verstecken und
zumindest für die Zeit des
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf zu isolieren
sodass er seine Anhänger nicht gegen
Putin organisiert und
mobilisiert der russische
Oppositionspolitiker glaubt nicht dass
die Behörden auf seine Anfrage antworten
werden er habe ein Zeichen setzen wollen
dass Russlands politische Gefangene
nicht einfach so verschwinden
dürfen und im heute journal Update dazu
dann auch ein Gespräch mit dem
Chefredakteur der Zeitung novay Gazetta
Europe es gibt Politiker in unserem Land
die gerne von Schuldkult sprechen und
einen Schlussstrich unter unsere
deutsche Vergangenheit setzen möchten
wie wichtig es ist zu erinnern nicht zu
vergessen zu verstehen was passieren
kann und wie schnell es passieren kann
das zeigen die antisemitischen Vorfälle
in unserem Land die seit dem 7 Oktober
massiv zugenommen haben auch die
deutsche Nachkriegsgesellschaft hat
versucht die nsgeschichte zu verdrängen
daher war es auch alles andere als
selbstverständlich dass am 20 dezember
1963 der Auschwitzprozess beginnen
konnte konte heute vor 60 Jahren Isabel
der
laweger sie sind empört dass man sie
filmt die 22 Angeklagten auf dem Weg zum
Frankfurter
auschwitzprzess apothekerärzte und
Kaufleute die bis dahin unbehelligt im
Nachkriegsdeutschland gelbt hatten sie
geben sich selbstbewusst und waren doch
an einem der größten Verbrechen der
deutschen Geschichte beteiligt fast 20
Jahre nach Kriegsende markieren die
Prozesse einen Wendepunkt das hier
wirklich ein breiten Öffentlichkeit
diese Verbrechen erstmals bekannt
geworden sind und zu Tage trat das
arbeitsteilig organisierte Prinzip der
Massenvernichtung in Auschwitz überhaupt
die Systematik der Vernichtung auch die
Funktionsweise der Bürokratie der der SS
Auschwitz über eine Million Juden sind
hier Opfer einer industriell
organisierten Vernichtung geworden nun
stehen Blog und rapportführer Ärzte und
Adjudanten vor Gericht wie Robert mulker
stellvertretender Lagerkommandant
a den
originaltonaufnahmen ich frage sie nun
ob sie davon gewusst haben dass die
Leute mit den Lastkraftwagen zu den Gas
davon BEK ich keine Kenntnis sie wollen
also sagen sie haben damals als sie
Adjutant waren nicht gewusst dass die
Lastkraftwagen eingesetzt wurden und die
zur Vergasung bestimmten zu den
Gaskammern zuin man fragte mich nicht
danach sie haben es nicht gewusst wollen
sie
sag über 300 Zeugen sagenus die meisten
tzüberlebende erstmals erfährt eine
breite Öffentlichkeit in Deutschland die
Details der Verbrechen Fritz Bauer der
unermütliche Ankläger der Frankfurter
auschwitzprozesse wollte genau das dass
sich die Deutschen ihrer
Mitverantwortung
stellen was die Leute nicht hören wollen
das ist dass es in unserem Leben eine
Grenze gibt wo wir nicht mehr mitmachen
dürfen Gerhard Wiese ist einer der
Staatsanwälte die nunmehr 95jährigen
empört noch immer dass die Täter während
des gesamten Prozesses kein Wort des
Bedauerns äußerten nein nein keine R
nein wir hatten immer gehofft dass
wenigstens einer aufsteht und was sagt
aber leider nein sie konnten alle nicht
bestreiten dass sie in Auschwitz waren
aber schlechtes böses haben wir da nicht
getan drei Angeklagte werden
freigesprochen die meisten bekommen
mehrjährige Freiheit Strafen und nur
sechs Angeklagte werden zu
lebenslangerhaft verurteilt der Prozess
sei aber aus heutiger Sicht nicht wegen
der Strafen allein wichtig gewesen ich
glaube dass es die Seele Deutschlands
gerettet hat
dass es dadurch bewiesen hat dass es
Rechtsstaatlichkeit in einem
Demokratisierungsprozess wiederentdeckt
hat und seit den Frankfurter Prozessen
und den vielen beweisen kann Auschwitz
in all seinen Dimensionen nicht mehr
geleugnet werden
und jetzt noch mal Nachrichten mit dir
kaiöve und mit einer klimafreundlichen
Nachricht in Deutschland wurde dieses
jah so wenig Energie verbraucht wie noch
nie seit der Wiedervereinigung doch
nicht allen ist zum Jubeln Z Mute denn
der Grund Valerie Haller in Frankfurt
ist die schwächelnde Konjunktur
energieintensive Industriezweige sind
die hohen Kosten ein Problem die
Wirtschaft mahnt immer wieder an dass
die vergleichsweise hohen Energiepreise
den Standort Deutschland im
internationalen Wettbewerb schwächt ja
so sehr dass die Industrie ihre
Produktion dauerhaft oder temporär
drosselt oder teilweise ins Ausland
verlagert das hinterlässt deutliche
Spuren beim Energieverbrauch gespart
wurde vor allem bei fossilen Energien
bei Mineralölprodukten ging der
Verbrauch um 5inhal % zurück Erdgas um
4,3 % und Braunkohle sogar um
22%. es gab aber auch in manchen
Bereichen Steigerungen beim Verbrauch
das liegt an der demographischen
Entwicklung laut Arbeit Gemeinschaft
Energiebilanzen sind in diesem Jahr rund
1,3 Millionen Menschen zugezogen ja und
auch das macht sich bemerkbar wurde denn
auch mehr gespart oder verbrauchen die
Menschen in Deutschland wieder mehr als
im vergangenen Jahr tatsächlich scheinen
sie wieder mehr zu verbrauchen obwohl es
deutlich wärmer war in dieser Heizsaison
als vor einem Jahr haben private
Haushalte in mehr Familienhäusern 12%
weniger sparsam geheizt als in der
Vorjahressaison das zeigen Daten von
Energiedienstleistern das kann sich aber
schnell wieder ändern denn kommendes
Jahr wird heizen Strom und Benzin all
das wird noch teurer unter anderem durch
deutlich höhere CO2 Preise und weil
preisbremsen gestrichen wurden danke an
die Frankfurter
Börse letztes Mal Bundesliga in diesem
Jahr mit sechs Partien von denen eine
schon durch ist nämlich Union Berlin
gegen den ersten fC Köln die Gastgeber
gewannen mit
2:0 opernänger Banos Spieler Moderator
Gunter Emmerlich galt als Talent und
fernsehlegende nun ist er im Alter von
79 Jahren gestorben seine Karriere
begann er in der DDR später eroberte er
auch im Westen die
Herzen singen war sein Leben egal wo
egal
[Musik]
wann
ddenine
ST Sänger aufiemlich allen deutschen
Bühen doch am liebsten sind dem Bass die
Bühnen von Opa und
Operette der gebürtige Thüringer ist für
sein Publikum vor allem der gemütliche
wortgewandte Sachse etwa 300 Tage im
Jahr ist dämmerlich unterwegs Stress der
Spuren hinterlässt einen Herzinfarkt
erleitet er mit3 das Verm zwar seine
Gewohnheiten zu ändern sein
Arbeitspensum hingegen nicht weniger zu
arbeiten das ist nicht geworden aber
aber alles andere was mir der Onkel
Doktor empfohlen hat das beherzige
ich die von Freunden für ihn
organisierte große Party zum 75
Geburtstag erträgt er mit Humor die
Veranstaltung war nicht nur schön
sondern auch ganz schön
lang weil viele und die armen Schweine
mussten mich alle loben ich hätte nicht
in deren Haut stecken natürlich gab vor
ein paar Tagen noch Witzel der
bodenständige Promi über seinen
lieblingsjobter Weihs geworden ja du
bist ja der der das rolemodell quasi von
dem Weihnachtsmann also ich bin der
Weihnacht dieser typische ärmerliche
Humor wird
[Musik]
fehlen schauen wir noch kurz auf die
Lottozahlen 4 17 18 25 31 44 Superzahl
ne weitere Gewinnzahlen gibt's unter
lottozdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
557 und jetzt können Sie mit Terra x vom
Sofa aus auf Reisen gehen mit dem
Bergretter Sebastian Ströbel und zwar
von der Zugspitze bis zum Dachstein Sofa
klingt gut machen wir jetzt auch Ihnen
noch einen schönen Abend und wenn Sie
wollen das heute journal Update um 0:15
Uhr machen sie es gut wo auch immer sie
sind
tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die sturmlage die
sich morgen einstellt die hat es in sich
schon das erste tief was uns erreicht
bringt an den Küsten orkanböhnen und das
auch in den höheren Lagen teilweise
können sich schwere Sturmböen bis ins
Flachland durchmischen in der Nähe von
Schauern und Gewittern bereits in der
Nacht haben wir in den höheren Lagen
sturmböhen und teilweise auch ergiebigen
Regen sonst wandern die Wolken
allmählich südostwärts mit Regen und
Schnee z.B im Erzgebirge Temperaturen
sinken dabei auf 0° an den Alpen und 7°
ganz im Westen morgen baut sich dann die
sturmlage allmählich von Nordwesten
Richtung Südosten auf und dabei ist
ergiebiger Regen dabei und an den Alpen
auch Schnee der kann auch ergbig sein in
den höheren Lagen gibt's
Schneeverwehungen und die
Windgeschwindigkeiten die haben es in
sich über 120 km pro Stunde an den
Küsten vor allem hier Richtung Nordsee
in den Bergen um 120 km pro Stunde und
im Flachland sind 70 bis 100 km pro
Stunde möglich und schwere sturmböhnen
dann vor allem in der Nähe von Schauern
und Gewittern Temperaturen dazu maximal
11° ganz im Westen und 5° im Süden am
freitags die Sturm age noch nicht durch
bei 3 bis 10° und am Samstag gibt es
eben auch noch keine Entwarnung und
damit einen schönen
Abend